it's such a connection because you have
this history together
even though there's 30 years i'm just as
anxious as everybody you know
oh i i bawled my eyes out i was so happy
the only way to end this is by working
together
so what do you say we're going to see
some amazing characters return
from the karate kid days so when you're
reading the scripts
realizing these folks are going to be
welcomed back onto the show
what was the sentiment there it's been a
highlight of doing the show
um have and everyone comes with their a
game it really has been
it's such a connection because you have
this history together
even though there's 30 years there's a
scene i have with tamlin
place kumiko where i say god it's been
30 years it feels like
five minutes and that is the truth that
was an honest
uh piece of dialogue i mean that's
there's a there's a spirit
among us and everyone has supported it
and and it's been such having that
okinawa section
in this coming season is really quite
beautiful and informs the story and
informs the side of larusso that you
don't know and he learns something that
he brings
into his story and into the
confrontations with johnny lawrence and
chris and so it's so well written in
that way but having all those actors and
and lisa um you know finally
uh being there when everyone's like when
is that gonna happen
it was uh it's like really said it is a
big party but there's something special
about the connection
you can speak for that as well yeah and
speaking of little alley
so might we see her in future episodes
enough to see
you will have to tune in to netflix when
that time comes
now okay we see johnny and daniel's
relationship look
they have been on separate pages for 35
years now and maybe or maybe not
they might be coming to some sort of a
truce maybe
but what do you think what what would it
take to end this rivalry once and for
all
i'm just thinking of the uh time they
went on the double date sort of thing at
the mexican restaurant yeah oh my god i
love
that moment like some more drinks and
double dates and uh
talking about everything and just i
don't know being happy and also just
wanting peace between the kids i think
might end up bringing them together it's
like
all right we gotta we gotta stop this
and we gotta be adults and be bigger
than that
so maybe that's the conversation i'll
have i was gonna say i think it's gonna
be alcohol and dude stuff that would
kind of be the thing like you know what
i mean like the like the speed wagon
thing like it's got to be like dude
stuff that like brings them together
yeah yeah especially for johnny's
character he needs a good old coors
light you know
you all have similar dynamics so i can't
wait to see how maybe you two come to a
truce at some sort of
time as well so we shall see i think the
idea of them coming together
is awesome i don't know like in practice
how
successful they're going to be because
they're very much
they've been at odds with each other you
know for the last 30 something years so
it'll definitely be interesting to see
you know if when that happens
um but i'm all for it you know i think
uh
we've seen time and time again how
similar
johnny and daniel are but at the same
time just how
it feels like you know oil and water the
two
kind of don't really mix well together
but i will say i think they have a lot
they can learn from each other i think
you know
johnny has a lot of great life lessons
and daniel has the same and as long as i
think they
keep their arms distance they can they
can work together but
but i think once one of them steps over
that line it's gonna be back to square
one just like we've seen you know in
seasons one and season two
yeah it's amazing what could happen when
folks work together
exactly you know what i'm saying what
was your reaction when you heard
you guys are going for season four
peyton
oh i i bawled my eyes out i was so happy
i remember um they they wanted to
zoom us like all the writers got
everyone together all the actors and
everyone together to zoom
and i remember just trying not i don't
know why i didn't want to show everyone
that i was just like
sitting there and then afterwards i
think i just sometimes i just sit in my
kitchen and i scream
because i'm so excited i'm getting out
of my house
i'm so excited you know to get to to see
my castmates to see my cobra kai family
it's been
a long minute so i'll be really excited
to get to get back in there with
everybody i'm so excited to get back to
kicking and punching things because
that's like the most fun